привів рішення подати у відставку чим
ерік порча все а ти мені закінчу все я
вирішив подати у відставку я йду з
посади начальника політик я заявляю
від своєї відставки
у дим злобними наземні реформатори
завищував і посади кувати дзвінів і хто ж і
самки шов бурити і вже практично на
втратила реформатору встав званого в
грузинського легіону вчора ніші владу
пукнув і на землю викрадемо айварас
абромавічус до наталія яресько
причин а я ж за вже ти сама опер
стару корумпована система та
політичний тест то включаючи роботу то
експерт en este вид ставок одягаю тя він
встиг на ній та на зимові характері
кицькам херлі для старої системи та
розлучення знаємо та bull удар це не їм
годині онлайн
президент порошенка та система прийняти
опери формам із зовнішнього рівня мікени
накласти так ті з системи і так само
консолідацію другої системи в Україні
віці не піддавайся чужинці
іноземці ще лаяти реформа тому що
система не може всіх людей
контролювати Україну на думку
експертів за 1 годину
фундаментальних змін в Україні, а самої
тихого бою ті олігарха
павловна вигляд ставка нових реформаторів
виробляючи дорощування wsus пертв і
можемо викл катиного політично
нестабільність у краї ним здається факт
team pro тема x з xii вонище реформи
через хвастання довгий не постраждають а не
думаю що реформа за ухвалення якнайшвидшого
намацували менше вправо від живота
мультя звичай на вибух access-list
варівати маяка вона знає денщик
експертів для
потім реформ в 1 годині все закладу там і
вид і сонячного диска засіки збоку
європейського союзу смоктати його я
брюстер ще нагорі вікна настановний
вид ставки реформаторів експерти
спустити цін на зайнятий із внутрішніми
проблемами
проти поважають диск на cowards більше ти
без достатнього збоку брюсселя реформа
в Україні знову може зупинитись